Series finales can be tough to pull off for
even the best TV shows.
They have to wrap all of the show's plotlines
and character arcs in a way that is satisfactory
and sensical.
Sometimes, that means a show will close on
a question mark to allow fans their own interpretations
or perhaps even room for a spin-off.
And while that might work with some programs,
an open ended finale can often seem so unfinished
that fans are left clamoring for answers years
after the fact.
To help resolve some of the most frustrating
show endings, here's a look at what showrunners
really meant for fans to take away from these
confusing conclusions.
Lost
For a show that was already redefining weird,
Lost's last episode really went off the rails.
The fifth season ended with Jack and the crew
setting off a hydrogen bomb on the island
while visiting the 1970's, so the sixth and
final season picked up with two separate timelines:
one where the survivors are still stuck on
the island in the present, and another where
the plane seemingly never crashed.
This alternate timeline soon revealed itself
to be much different than the original, and
many of the characters were living completely
different lives.
The final episode revealed that this timeline
was actually the afterlife.
Carlton Cuse and Damon Lindelof later explained
that the afterlife plotline was supposed to
demonstrate how the events on the island weren't
purgatory, as many suspected.
Unfortunately, the message was so, well, lost
in the chaos of the sideways world exploration
that even they couldn't really explain all
the finite details.
The Sopranos
The fade-to-black finish for The Sopranos
was so unexpected that many viewers thought
their cable feed had been interrupted when
it happened.
Fans of the show had spent months and months
speculating about what incredible drama would
befall Tony Soprano and his family to close
out such an eventful show, but … none of
that happened.
Instead, Tony, his wife Carmela, and their
kids met up for dinner -- after an excruciatingly
drawn-out parallel parking job by Meadow.
With Journey's "Don't Stop Believing" blaring
out over all the inaction, Tony noticed a
suspicious man lurking around the diner and
...
"(Ding)"
"Don't stop"
According to series creator David Chase, the
ending implied that Tony was always going
to be paranoid as a result of his mafioso
history and that endings for guys like Tony
tend to happen just that quickly and unexpectedly.
Thanks to some frame-by-frame analyses after
the fact, it's pretty clear that the guy Tony
was eyeing, who went to the bathroom nearby
his table, probably ended his life right then
and there.
But the fact that Chase chose not to actually
show his death was irritating, considering
the show wasn't shy about showcasing some
serious brutality before.
Parks and Recreation
The final season of Parks and Recreation jumped
forward in time a few years to 2017, in which
Leslie Knope has become a regional director
of the National Parks Service.
But if that time-tripping wasn't enough, the
series finale skipped even further ahead to
detail the next few years in the lives of
all the main characters, particularly Leslie
and her husband, fellow Pawnee government
worker Ben Wyatt.
Both are approached to run for governor of
Indiana, with Leslie said to have served two
terms in the post, while Ben went on to serve
in Congress.
"Joe Biden knows his way around a seafood
risotto."
Then, much farther along in the future, they
attend the funeral of Jerry Gergich with a
Secret Service detail in tow.
That means either Leslie or Ben is President
of the United States, but who is it?
Show creator Mike Schur, inspired by the ambiguity
of the finale of The Sopranos, says he felt
"there was room for one big question mark."
Schur told Variety that he "wanted people
to be able to fill in their own blanks and
make up their own minds."
Considering the fact that Leslie Knope always
had Oval Office ambitions, it was probably
her, but the fact that we didn't get to find
out for sure meant fans had to order extra
waffles to cope.
30 Rock
NBC's 30 Rock seemed to have a relatively
straightforward finale, going full meta by
having their faux show, TGS, wrap in conjunction
with the real show's end.
But there was one element of the big finish
that was extremely odd.
In the very last scene of the show, which
takes place several generations in the future,
Liz Lemon's granddaughter is all grown up
and is pitching a show about her grandmother
to the new head of the network, who just so
happens to be... an apparently immortal Kenneth?
Throughout the show, Kenneth was an NBC page
who was painted as something of a simpleton,
but in retrospect, the show might've been
building to the reveal that Kenneth was a
timeless creature all along.
After all, how many references did Kenneth
make to old actors and songs that were so
obscure even those in the entertainment business
around him couldn't keep up?
"I was pretty addicted to coke back in my
Wall Street days."
Mad Men
After nearly a decade of failed marriages,
salacious affairs, a bunch of booze, and a
deep dive into his abandoned identity, Donald
Draper escaped his life as a snazzy Madison
Avenue executive and sought solace in a hippie
commune.
His journey to rock bottom was the very fabric
of Mad Men's seven seasons, so when he showed
up at a California hideaway desperately weeping
over his mistakes and emotional disconnections,
it seemed like Don might finally change his
ways.
But that final shot of him peacefully meditating
en masse was not the end-all be-all for the
creative genius' days in the sun.
The series ended with a credits cutaway to
the famous 1971 Coca-Cola commercial of a
cross-cultural singing group chanting about
wanting to buy the world a Coke and indicated
that Don's take away from so much self-discovery
was really just another awesome ad idea.
Mad Men creator Matthew Weiner later agreed
that Don indeed remained an ad man to the
end, as the commercial suggested, saying,
"Why not end this show with the greatest commercial
ever made?
I am not [into] ambiguity for ambiguity's
sake.
But it was nice to have your cake and eat
it too, in terms of what is advertising, who
is Don and what is that thing?"
As a result, viewers were left thirsty for
more, so the choice of a soda ad was certainly
inspired.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!